in 1963 an anthropologist called Edward
T hall realized there was no term for
the study of personal space so he
invented one because that's the sort of
thing that anthropologists like to do he
called it proxemics and it caught on
because it turned out to be a good way
to let people think about abstract
questions like how do you react when
someone gets too close too fast so what
we have here is an robotic spider dress
so it's an it's a dress that has
mechanical limbs that are reacting and
it is reacting on yeah you coming closer
so you come in here there's two
proximity sensors here so they are in
the balls of the design and they are
sensing when when you come close there
are twelve states that are
pre-programmed and basically it's
deciding between one of those twelve
states in order to create one of these
animations in his book Hall proposes for
distance zones the public the social the
personal and the intimate and well in
the sort of life coaching seminars that
people get sent to in middle management
textbooks those zones are treated as
gospel as this is how everyone behaves
but in wholes own words the zones were
only a first approximation they were
based on a tiny sample of university
educated Americans they weren't
representative of human behavior in
general and they weren't meant to me
they were crude stereotypes actually a
lot of the book is crude stereotypes
there's a whole section just titled the
French which describes them as
essentially involved with each other I
use 3d modeling in order to create this
design I'm using a software called Maya
and then we 3d printed it out so it is
2d printed in an island in a technique
called
selective laser sintering so you can see
here a lot of like difficult geometries
that are very very thin at places and
they're very delicate the technique of
selective laser sintering means that you
have basically a big box of powder which
is in this case nylon and you have your
laser beam and a sintering out is
materializing exactly the model you're
you created so basically when you take
this design out you're taking it from a
big basket of powder and all the powder
is falling off the proximity sensors are
in this dress so they're in
front of the dress and they are sensing
so they're sensing in a beam that's
being sent to the tuner microcontroller
which is in the back piece as a
scientific theory the field of proxemics
is vague whole just sort of thought it
up and stated it in his book and there
aren't many studies backed up with
rigorous examination and statistics it's
mostly a set of observations and ideas
but despite what some hyper rationalist
people might think those have value to
being aware of the hidden rules that
guide us asking why we act the way we do
that can be a powerful tool for figuring
out the way that the world works and
visualizing something that isn't just
invisible but it's actually an abstract
concept that can be a really powerful
way to help understand yourself thanks
to a milk VIP rekt her dress is on
display at the Autodesk gallery in San
Francisco until March 2017 pull down the
description for more links about her the
dress and the gallery